and nine members of her family used to
live here before Israel missiles turned
their home to Rubble during fighting
with the Islamic Jihad group in August
2022 they lost everything
because we're on the border all the
shells and missiles intercepted by the
Iron Dome fall on us so when the Israeli
strikes began we quickly rushed out of
our home along with our neighbors the
next day we sent my son back to fetch
some belongings for the children but he
found our home completely destroyed
and it wasn't the first time
in 2014 El zwedi's home was partially
damaged in an Israeli airstrike and
repaired by the U.N relief and works
Agency for Palestine refugees
these days Miriam her children and
grandchildren lived together in a rented
apartment which is all they can afford
most buildings here have been rebuilt
since they have been damaged in previous
conflicts and those living in this
neighborhood fear for their lives
because they're forced to flee their
homes every time violence escalates
entire neighborhoods on gaza's North and
Eastern borders are constantly under
attack
families say they are hit by shells from
Israeli tanks and bullets from machine
guns sometimes Farmers land is bulldozed
and Shepherds take cover from gunpire
not far from what used to be Miriam's
homebade and his family have returned to
theirs it was rebuilt recently after
being destroyed for a second time in
Israel's 2021 war on Gaza
was injured he says they never feel safe
once we hear that any tension is taking
place even before the first bullet is
fired we pack and leave our home because
the Israelis find their tanks without
prior notice and in any direction they
fire randomly at us
helps with the Reconstruction of houses
for Palestinians living in Border areas
putting it under additional Financial
strain there is an enormous burden on
unrua to meet this need
after the conflict in May 21
we appealed to the International
Community for funding we have either
rebuilt or repaired over 7 000 houses
here in Gaza to make sure that people
have the bare minimum acceptable level
of shelter or housing because of the
constant Wars and rounds of escalation
most Palestinians in Gaza do not feel
safe but those who live near the borders
are the most vulnerable because they
have nowhere else to go
Al Jazeera Gaza